good morning john i recently noticed
that days since hank green started a new
thing.com hasn't updated in 81 days have
i been doing nothing in the last 81 days
no so honestly as much as because i want
to get my own head wrapped around all of
this as you know i'd like to share what
i've been up to
here's a video about what the heck i'm
doing so for a long time now every
monday i record journey to the micro
cosmos and every tuesday i go in and i
shoot scishows and some tuesdays i also
shoot bizarre beasts i don't write any
of those things anymore i might have a
little bit of editorial input here and
there but mostly i just read out loud
that's a lot of my job now i've also
been working a lot today on the micro
cosmos microscope we did a kickstarter
from microscope mine is right over there
it's finally shipping out but we are
missing a piece we think it got lost in
transit but we're shipping everybody's
out and that final piece will go out
when we get it which hopefully will be
soon in the evenings i've been
assembling crash course coins i have a
lot of coin boxes in my house right now
i'm doing that myself because it feels
like a way to say thank you to the
people who supported crash course
through that thing it's taking more time
than it would if someone else did it but
i don't know i just feel like i should
do it also i make about 20 science tick
tocks a month and about 60 not science
tick tocks a month why i'm doing that as
a bit of a mystery to me but i'm trying
not to ask too many questions i'm always
doing a little bit of prep for tangents
sometimes that's writing science poems
tangents is our science trivia game show
podcast it's 30 minutes long and it is
so good it's been climbing up the
science charts watching it get higher
and higher is very exciting you can
start anywhere but why not do the
elephant episode that just came out
because it was very good likewise always
doing some prep for dear hank and john
though having deboki help with the
science editorial part of that has made
that easier currently prepping for an
important upcoming meeting with a
partner for crash course could be very
good but have to impress them and show
how amazing we are which should be easy
because we are also working on crash
courses partnership with asu which has
given me a lot of insight into how
education really functions in the u.s
and like where it's letting people down
i'm renegotiating a contract right now
which is not my favorite thing also
trying to figure out what to do about
shipping costs generally which have gone
up a lot which is just how things are
but if our ups male innovations rep is
watching this hey could you could we
just budge a little bit on that one
thing you know what it is also getting
ready to market our second year of the
awesome socks club one of the things i
finished today was the list of
tick-tockers who i want to work with on
promoting the socks this year thank you
to everybody who's a member of the song
club they have so far raised over 600
thousand dollars for partners in health
and they're really good socks and of
course i'm also being helped by a ton of
people in all of these things who i'm
all trying to be a good boss to which
involves like clearly communicating
goals and values and like what ways we
do things are good and what ways we do
things are not so good and also that
stuff involves figuring out how to make
money so that we can treat people well
which is like i'm grateful for all of it
but it's you know it's a lot of pressure
i don't always get it right i don't
always know what i'm doing everyone is
still learning and like i'm a guy who
isn't fantastic at focus
as evidenced by this list and yeah john
there are also those other two things
that we really wanted to do and that we
wanted to have out by christmas and then
it doesn't like we're going to have out
by christmas and that's a little bit
frustrating but it is what it is they
will happen eventually and they will be
great when they happen and they will be
greater when they happen because we
waited and am i trying to write a space
mystery novel sure maybe but like that
doesn't mean it's gonna happen also this
is oren's first week of pre-k so we're
like putting him at his school and it's
cute and sad and scary and i'm planning
my 15th wedding anniversary look it's a
lot but it wouldn't be this way if i
didn't like it this way i don't like to
focus but there is one thing that i do
every single day and it is that i go and
i check to see whether or not apple is
about to put those sd card slots back
into the laptops
please all right putting it all out
there has made me feel a little bit
better am i overwhelmed yes but are
there good reasons for that yes and will
all of these things get done they will
perfectly no but done
but done john i'll see you on tuesday